good day my name is Edmund and welcome
to my talk on estimating rainstorm
losses using Mathematica
yeah well good morning everyone thank
you for joining me my name is Edmund
Robinson and I work as a actual analyst
with validus reinsurance limited based
out of Bermuda today I'm just going to
go over a interactive workflow on how to
have Mathematica can be utilized to
estimate wind storm losses generally
what happens there will be a wind storm
and in this case we're going to look at
a hurricane things will happen on the
ground and at that time insurers and
reinsurers those being insurers that
ensure ensures then once I sort of get
information on what has happened how
much damage has occurred and so they can
start making moves to set aside funds to
address the claims that eventually going
to come in so a bit about my background
I spent some time in financial industry
doing portfolio attribution analytics
and then recently switched over to the
reinsurance industry where I did a I did
risk management analytics for emerging
risk and and now I'm moving into
actuarial analysis with in particular
actuarial pricing so one of the reasons
before we get too deep into it one of
the things that I like about using the
Wolfram language is that it puts at your
fingertips many many knowledge domains
and you don't really have to go out to
search to learn how to use well you
don't have to go out to search to find
packages or products to allow you to
access those domains because all of this
information and plenty of functions are
there available for you to use and this
is one example so in this workflow what
I've listed here are just a few of the
domains that this workflow covers you
can see we're going to be doing data
import navigation Geographic
visualization and geodetic computation
geometric computation and and you'll
have this slide and under each one of
these areas I just give you an idea of
some of the
functions that are being used from those
knowledge domains knowledgebase we're
gonna be doing things with entity
framework and administrative divisions
probability and statistics will touch on
parametric and non-parametric
distributions random variates cumulative
and probability density functions we're
also gonna do a bit of parallel
computing numerical computation data
visualization of presentation and even
some basic user interface construction
so all of these knowledge domains and
this is a tiny tiny fraction of what the
wolfram leg which provides you we're
gonna make use of in this presentation
so again what I'm doing is presenting
I'm going to be going to be looking at
third-party GIS data and we're going to
import that into Mathematica and do some
manipulation and combination of that
with with some data so that we can
estimate this potential loss from this
event some of the interesting things
that you can do and this is from the
Wolfram volume visualization is that you
can have a look at to see what exactly
are the properties of a of a tropical
cyclone or hurricane so this link here
will take you to that Wolfram
visualization I've only made one tweak
to those functions and I was just
because we are in the southern
hemisphere I just changed the equations
very slightly such that the vortex would
rotate kind of clockwise instead of
clockwise and so we can see here wind
direction and even in air pressure so
it's a low-pressure system in the center
and I mean we've got higher pressures on
the outside so that's just see you under
if you've never heard or seen or know
anything about a hurricane that'd give
you some information what are the steps
that we're gonna go through we're going
to collect some storm GIS files we're
going to then imma take a look at what's
inside of that file the the file type is
a very data rich file type is a lot of
information in it and I use the
technique here that helps us to navigate
that that sort of
rich file-type we're going to simulate
some contract losses within the path of
the storm some contract locations within
the path of the storm we're gonna
simulate some losses from those
contracts and then we're going to
analyze analyze that set of information
to produce some that set of data to
produce some information so first things
first where can we get some storm GIS
files the u.s. National Hurricane Center
has a GIS page where you can download
Geo Tiff's shape files and other
information on current storms and on
path storms it has lots of different
information in it and also the US
National Weather Service also has
information where you can get on sort of
flood a flash flood risk from current
like inland storms ongoing and also you
can get River outlooks and other
information so if you wanted to see what
that looks like where that is if we're
on the National Hurricane Center website
this is just their landing page so
thankfully no activities going on right
now you can see Bermuda actually right
here above the Oh that little speck in
the middle of the Atlantic but if you
come up here to data and tools you
actually have to click the data and
tools header header you'll come to this
analysis tool page if you click this GIS
data pay link it'll take you here to
their GIS data products and then you can
look at all the different things that
they have you know wind speed
probabilities potential storm surge
flood all this information is available
for you for free to download and analyze
in in whatever pack in your projects in
your notebooks okay so let's go and grab
one of these what we're gonna use for
this example is hurricane Matthew a from
2016 it actually made its way through
the Caribbean and so and then raked
itself up along the the eastern the
eastern side of the US so I'm just gonna
go directly in and just grab the
this latest file from NOAA and was going
to do a slight transformation on it so
I'm just grabbing the file name and then
I'm putting it inside of a data set
because this is a very rich a very rich
file type that has lots of information
in it so let's look at some of that
information one thing that it has are
the wind swaths it also has the wind
radii as long and as well as a lot of
other data so you just get these running
so you can see here it came along
through the Caribbean so this outer sort
of darker purple is the the area that
experienced tropical storm-force winds
this inner sort of dark blue is the area
that experienced hurricane force or less
up from category once a category two and
then this sort of light blue in the
middle is the area that experienced
major hurricane force so that'll be
category three and above but we also
have inside of this file wind radii so
that weekend if we can just position
this just so let's try doing this we can
then sort of scroll along and we can see
at any particular date what that sort of
wind radii forecast looked like as well
and they do it in quadrants so you know
again the the wind radii corresponds to
this wind swath so this purple area is
the area that experienced tropical force
the the darker blue is the area that
experienced captain want to cap to force
and then the the light blue is the area
that experienced major so Kathy and
above force hurricane winds of course
winds so this is if we if we grab that
file and sort of put it into a data set
this is all the information that is in
that one file so we can see the radii
the wind swaths the actual line the
track line and then the points at each
of the center of the storm at each
particular day and then of course this
is navigable what we were using what I
was using above was
the the wind soif geometry and the radii
geometry to draw all of those those
images and on a geographic mileage a
graph we can take a quick look if you if
you want we could just expand this here
and you can have a quick look of the the
code that was used to do that so the
first thing I do is I just collect the
synapse times here and then in a
manipulate using overlay I overlay the
the radii on top of the wind swath that
I that we created here all right so now
we can we have an idea of where it went
and how intense it was when it was there
let's move into doing something with it
now lost models and geo encoded data in
the industry are highly coveted so we're
not gonna go off and connect to any in
particular databases that anything we
can do for this presentation is just
simulate some of that information so we
know that the area that we're looking
for the area that has the most insurance
penetration is the u.s. South Atlantic
states in the area that this storm
passed through so what we can do using
some of the information available to us
from the Wolfram knowledge base we can
just go off and we can say okay find me
all of the US continental US states so
that's what I'm doing to get all of
these sort of gray air blue states with
the white borders and then I can say oh
for a particular set of states that I'm
interested in so these US South Atlantic
states get me as some additional
information about that so I can sort of
show that differently so all I've done
here is just brought in this information
all from the Wolfram's chord created
data and just labeled each state with a
tooltip with their name and their state
flag so we can just you know we know
where what we're looking at and just
some additional information because I've
never saw state flags I didn't realize
that they had been US states had their
own flags so what we can do now since we
know that this is the area that we want
to to work with for our simulation for a
presentation
what I'm going to do now is simulate
5,000 contract locations within these
states now if you were in some of the
the talks early in the week this is
actually is going to be a lot easier to
do in the coming version because they
actually will from employees actually
demonstrated a Geo
random point random geo point so what
abut because this is 11 3 and I don't
have access to that all I'm doing is I'm
just taking the polygons from this area
converting them so that the just
removing the geo the geo position tag
that's in them so then they just become
points and then I can get random points
within that and then I just convert them
back to geo positions so if we do that
and then we can plot those positions we
can see these are the 5000 sort of home
or business or skyscraper whatever
locations in the area that we're going
to do our analysis in so this is very
interesting because we're combining
geodetic computation with with
probability and and random variate
generation different disciplines that
were mixing together to create something
and it's all under one roof all under
one package which which is what I quite
enjoy so that's great we can see all
these places which ones actually had
something happen to them
so what I do next is I say ok well let's
go this is a the data set that we looked
at earlier and I'm just using that data
set there's a function called query that
data set will sort of automatically use
if you start to give it commands inside
of square brackets so I'm taking the
second item which I know is the the wind
swath regions and I am sorting that by
geo area because I want the smallest one
first and to go up and then I'm picking
out the ones with geo within Q that the
contracts that lie within those wind
swaths and then as I roll back up I take
the compliment so the smallest one only
as things in it that belong to it but
the next swath out will have all of its
points plus the points from the smaller
one so I'm just doing the complement
folding that outwards so I only get so
I'm gonna end up with three sets of geo
positions one that only contains the
major storm one that only contains the
so the major hurricane one day when it
contains hurricane and one they didn't
contains the tropical storm and then we
can plot that with a bit of extra
information and then to get this plot
that shows us okay exactly what has
happened to our portfolio of contracts
so we can see here that we have just
over 1600 we're exposed to tropical
force winds adjusted over 300 were
exposed to hurricane winds and 53 were
exposed to major hurricane winds so
already we have some information
immediately available to us that we can
start to work on now that's great we
know where they were we know what winds
they experienced now let's figure out
what does that mean for the insurer or
that holds those policies and the
reinsurer that has reinsured those
policies so again we're going to just
simulate this because we're not gonna
connect to any particular IP to get this
information from any particular company
so what I'm going to do then is I'm
going to assimilate the loss for each
contract using a pressure distribution
and in order to do that I'm actually
going to randomly generate some Pareto
distributions in order to have that
happen so I'm gonna use these a
prototype okay so we'll just set up
those and we're going to just show you
real quick what family of distributions
I'm going to use so you can see here
this is Pareto and all I'm going to do
is varying K and and and gamma here and
so as I generate these things randomly
I'll be picking one of these lost
distributions for each one of those
contract locations so let's just do that
real quick
this is just to you know you can just
see that yep that's indeed
what we're dealing with here and we will
so again at this point because you know
which individual contract has
experienced what loss you can then start
to do things if you want to make slight
adjustments to their loss function
because they experience higher winds and
the others now that you know which
individual contracts have done that you
can you can make those changes here we
don't and then this is just to show you
that yes I have indeed I'm done that I'm
taking the first 20 and just showing you
these are all of these symbolics just
waiting there to be used from the random
the random generation we of course we
held these two various variables
constant parameters constant and the
other two we regenerated so let's
simulate using Monte Carlo some losses
here so what I'm going to do is simulate
a hundred thousand events for each of
around about twelve thousand contracts
so that's gonna be one hundred and
twenty million random observations that
we're gonna make I'm gonna do this in
parallel because why would you do it in
serial oh if you've been it's so easy to
do it in parallel so all this does let's
just start that running you see here
it's launching this this machine can
handle four kernels I don't know why
it's taking so long
oh could not provide a sub kernel
license so I guess the version that this
is on does not have sub kernel what
version is this just this mustn't be
eleven three well if there this was a
version that allowed parallel processing
I think this must be desktop I don't
think it ran let's just check check to
see if it ran oh it did run good so we
didn't get into the parallel processing
and it took about nine seconds to run in
serial and that was both generating the
120 million random variates and also
totaling $100,000 mule ations as well so
very fast and and quick to do so what do
we want to do now let's just look at the
eight
iteration over cross all of our random
variate so you can see that you know
there are definitely twelve twelve
hundred you know you see 197 I saw 1197
here and you see the other three on the
sides 1200 and all and everybody's
generated nicely alright so we got the
data let's do something with it of
course what we would like to do is
visualize what that loss how that loss
is distributed across that contract of
portfolios we can do that quite easily
here I'm just forcing it to use bin
widths of 5 million but this is a long
tailed distribution so if we said ok
let's see the full tail this part here
it's just this tiny part here and then
you can see there's gonna be some losses
way out here for some larger properties
or industrial type buildings or
something from our simulation ok that
looks nice let's see what else we can we
can make from that we can create a
smooth kernel distributions from that
which now we can use analytically to do
to do some some other property from its
property so first thing we want to do is
just make sure this works
is this truly a PDF well yes it
integrates to 1 from 0 to infinity as we
can see here so we're now getting into
Symbolics and numeric computation and
everything's just flowing through quite
nicely so let's let's see what that
looks like let's do something to help
people have a look at that and we can
just combine those guys together quite
easily and we now have the histogram and
the smooth kernel overlaid okay that's
interesting what else can we work with
let's what's really important to to the
industry are we always hear this in the
news you know it was a one in two
hundred year event or one in five
hundred year event what they use when
that happens is they're interested in
var which is value at risk and T bar
which is total value at risk we can
calculate that from our simulations by
taking the floor we you know we
calculate the index of that return
period you take
and then you take the floor so they'll
give you the value at risk and that same
calculation but then you gonna take from
that index all the way to the end and
that'll take the mean of that and
that'll give you the the total value at
risk okay so we can calculate those from
a simulation can we also do that with
our density function well yet we can so
we can see from the simulation and we
can see from the density function
they're quite close can we do it can we
do the T bar what we can do now is we
can actually set up statistical notation
the equation for total value at risk is
exactly this and you'll see this in all
literature it's the value at risk times
the probability that X is greater than
equal to the sorry is greater than the
value at risk over 1 minus alpha this
being alpha times the expected value
that X minus the value at risk given
that X is greater than the value at risk
so you can put in your formulas and your
information exactly how they appear in
your text switch which completely
removes any it significantly reduces any
chances for error because what it is
that you see and how you look at things
mathematically you can actually put that
information directly into your your
workbooks and into your workflows and
then it's easy to calculate four more
years so this is the one at 50 101 or
250 and you can spruce that up a bit by
adding some formatting and then you can
even go a stage further and say well you
know I've see you've got the one 150 100
250 I really want to see a different a
different return period other than the
ones that you've provided how how can we
work that out well you can add just a
little bit of additional code and now we
can see that we've added that last row
so that the user or whoever's looking at
this report can select their own return
period in addition to the standard ones
if they have if they had some interest
and then we can also do some interesting
things like looking at truncated t-bar
where you're not looking over from the
from your return point to the end but
you're looking at between two between
two return periods and so here we're
looking at the truncated t-bar between
that's 1 + 10 + 1 + 100 and we can play
along with this and look at different
t-bar
Changez okay so running quickly out of
time but we can also look at the the CDF
histogram of the losses I'm just gonna
run all these at once and just talk
about them as they come up we can look
at the cumulative density function and
then we can sort of look at this event
in the context of other events so you
can see that we've had I've put here two
three other events in the context of the
lost distribution of this event and then
we can sort of analyze that in terms of
a loss instead of a return period so
above we were looking at things in terms
of return period here we're looking at
things in terms of a loss so as I vary
the the loss the percentile and its
return period comes up so this event in
contacts event two in context of the
current event was a one in forty four
year event and then we can sort of put
it all together to do some sort of
report so you can use this we've got
create document or you can have this
deploy to the cloud to the to your
private cloud or to to the Wolfram cloud
and you can sort of start to get out
information so you can combine things so
I wanted to share this so you can
combine things and it's quite easy all
I've done here is taking the plot that
I've done before and I've inserted as an
epilogue this interactive table so now
this table has a an annotation that
actually is an interactive calculation
that's going on calculating those return
periods as we go and then finally we can
throw all this together so our our
Geographic plot our and other
information into sort of a little
dashboard and this is let's just make
this a little smaller this 100 yep into
an interactive dashboard that again can
be deployed so you can look at these
things on the cloud or in a CDF
Enterprise CDF or things like that so so
there you have it an interesting way I
mean I think of we've used quite a lot
of technologies from different
disciplines to quickly sort of get
something in and push something out that
that gives us information that we didn't
have
before thank you any any questions